a commuter van reduced to a burned-out
shell
in west kabul it was destroyed by a bomb
30 minutes later yet another transport
van was hit
two separate attacks on one road a few
kilometers apart
unfortunately the minivan was targeted
when i got here i saw two wounded
victims and dead bodies
we then took the injured to hospital
most of the people who live in this
neighborhood of kabul are from the
hazara ethnic community
who are predominantly shia in a largely
sunni society
armed groups linked to isil have
declared war against them
there have been similar bombings in the
area earlier this month several
civilians were killed when four minivans
were bombed
and in may about 80 people mostly girls
were killed
when their school was attacked hundreds
of afghans are killed or injured every
month in attacks like these
people who live here are bracing for
more violence
from what i can see the situation in the
area is very critical and the number of
casualties in this attack may increase
i still haven't been able to find my
friend as a cell phone appears to be off
despite this rise in violence
afghanistan is in the middle of a peace
agreement
the u.s says it will withdraw all its
forces and that of nato's by september
11th
it's a plan that's led to some tension
among the allies in recent weeks
negotiations between the afghan
government the taliban
and other parties have resumed in qatar
but
the violence back home appears to be
escalating
katya lopez al jazeera